[Musica]
6.127
6.127 sono le morti sul lavoro in Italia
negli ultimi 5 anni
una media di oltre 1200 morti l'anno
ci troviamo di fronte a un'Italia e un
mondo in cui la sicurezza sul lavoro
viene visto come un ostacolo un costo
extra un rallentamento un i soldi che
avanzano del budget se avanzano li
lasciamo per la sicurezza
fino a quando non succedono le tragedie
Luana 22 anni mamma di un bimbo di 5
morta incastrata in un macchinario
Sabri 23 anni perde la vita schiacciata
da una pressa
Layla 40 anni
morta dopo essere stata schiacciata
dalla fustellatrice a cui lavorava
Giuliano
18 anni
stava svolgendo uno stage per acquisire
crediti pare che si trovasse da solo nei
pressi di un macchinario quando una
lastra di ferro la colpito è morto poco
dopo l'impatto
potrei andare avanti per ore a elencare
nomi cognomi età e come sono morti sul
posto del lavoro
le domande sono tante come può succedere
perché nessuno fa niente perché
continuiamo a parlare di incidenti
tragici morti sul lavoro morti bianche
perché non si parla mai di soluzioni
ogni anno si contano oltre due milioni
di vittime per incidenti sul lavoro ai
quali si aggiungono 313 milioni di
infortuni
l'organizzazione mondiale del Lavoro
definisce tutto ciò uno dei principali
problemi sanitari a livello globale con
una spesa di oltre 3 miliardi di dollari
l'anno
ogni giorno
muoiono di lavoro
6.400 persone ogni giorno
è una cifra impressionante
la strage nel mondo del lavoro continua
giorno dopo giorno quasi nella totale
indifferenza
le cause delle morti sul lavoro sono
tante
in primis la mancanza di cultura degli
Imprenditori che li porta a considerare
la sicurezza come un rallentamento o un
costo eccessivo
a questo si aggiunga la poca formazione
dei lavoratori e la loro scarsa
consapevolezza del diritto alla tutela
del Lavoro la sicurezza sul lavoro è un
diritto è un dovere dei lavoratori
probabilmente vi chiederete chi sono
così giovane su questo palco ma
soprattutto perché ha 26 anni io abbia
deciso di affrontare un percorso tanto
complicato quanto tortuoso perché la
sicurezza sul mondo del lavoro qual è
l'obiettivo di fondo
ecco per me sicurezza sul mondo del
lavoro è un mezzo per raggiungere la mia
Mission
salvare vite umane
la sicurezza e l'imprenditorialità han
sempre fatto parte del Dna di famiglia a
partire da mia nonna
imprenditrice Negli anni cinquanta
un'epoca in cui le donne non potevano
essere né imprenditrici né indipendenti
fino a mio padre che da solo dal nulla
si è creato una realtà che da oltre 30
anni produce commercializza dispositivi
di protezione individuale
a 22 anni quando ho iniziato il mio
percorso imprenditoriale nel Regno Unito
quello che più mi ha spinto è stata
l'opportunità di business che vidi in
questo settore e la voglia e la
necessità di creare qualcosa di mio
a 26 anni tornata in Italia qualcosa è
cambiato
tornata in Italia ho potuto toccare con
mano quel numero di cui parlavo
all'inizio
6.127
6.127 morti sul lavoro
ora non sopporto il continuare a sentire
di notizie tragiche di morti sul lavoro
e questo mi spinge e mi esorta ogni
giorno a perseguire Questo obiettivo e
rendere il posto di lavoro un luogo
sicuro per tutti
salvare vite umane è l'energia pulsante
del mio lavoro
esserci dove le persone non possono
tutelarsi da sole
esserci prima che gli incidenti
succedano per Mostrare i rischi che
stavano percorrere ed esserci anche
quando gli incidenti succedono per
cercare di gestire al meglio l'emergenza
Forse esagero ma mi piace definirci
supereroi perché quello che facciamo si
è fatto bene Con etica dedizione ed
esperienza ci porta immense
soddisfazioni e sapete qual è la
soddisfazione più grande
il numero zero ovvero Zero incidenti e
zero morti
probabilmente vi chiederete Come è
possibile passare da 6.127 a 0 come è
possibile raggiungere questo traguardo
così ambizioso
Io credo fortemente che si debba
ripartire da due pilastri cultura e
prevenzione
cultura perché è fondamentale partire
dai giovani è fondamentale insegnare
nelle scuole l'importanza della
sicurezza sul lavoro perché noi giovani
siamo il futuro di domani siamo quelli
che sosterranno il mondo di domani ma
solo tutti insieme possiamo cambiare
questa triste realtà
vi faccio un esempio che è facilmente
collegabile alla sicurezza ed è la
cintura di sicurezza fino a qualche anno
fa o perlomeno quando io ero piccolina
mi ricordo che quasi nessuno si metteva
la cintura di sicurezza
anzi il problema più grande era il
rumore fastidioso il Beep Beep che
l'auto faceva quando non ti mettevi la
cintura
ad oggi la maggior parte delle persone
la prima cosa che fa quando sali in auto
è mettersi la cintura di sicurezza e
questo perché si è creata una cultura la
cintura di sicurezza e si è capito che
la cintura di sicurezza è prevenzione
quindi basterebbe poco basterebbe molto
poco basterebbe mettersi la cintura
perché è vero la cintura può darti
fastidio può stringerti ma tutti noi
accettiamo questo piccolo fastidio
consapevoli che puoi eliminare
conseguenze molto molto gravi
e quindi come vi dicevo basterebbe poco
basterebbe un cambio d'approccio per
salvare moltissime vite
prevenzione è quindi il secondo
imprescindibile Pilastro ed è per me la
soluzione e la parola chiave
come vi dicevo esserci fa parte della
mia Mission
esserci prima che gli incidenti
succedono per Mostrare i rischi che
stavano percorrere perché spesso sono
inconsapevoli
ma essersi sempre costantemente e
monitorare la sicurezza 24 ore su 24
sembra impossibile
sembra perché la realtà è un'altra e ve
lo dimostro se vi dico 2020 cosa vi
viene in mente sicuramente covid
pandemia quarantena lockdown tutto vero
vero anche che è stato un periodo che ci
ha permesso di interfacciarci e di
scoprire nuove realtà prima del dovuto
in quel periodo e quindi durante il
primo lockdown come la maggior parte
delle persone non potevamo lavorare ma
soprattutto non potevamo continuare a
monitorare la sicurezza in settore ad
altissimo rischio
un pomeriggio di lockdown vedo mia
sorella giocare con un visore di realtà
aumentata e lì nasce l'idea e insieme
pensiamo e creiamo il progetto Smart
ovvero l'utilizzo della realtà assistita
a favore dei servizi per la sicurezza
questo ci ha permesso in un periodo
complicato in cui non si poteva
viaggiare non si poteva muoversi di
continuare a monitorare la sicurezza in
settore ad alto rischio
e il progetto Smart progetto di realtà
assistita
ha funzionato talmente bene che
tutt'oggi continua ad esistere proprio
perché ci permette di essere
onnipresenti e quindi senza limiti né di
spazio né di tempo e continuare a
monitorare la sicurezza
ad oggi sono tornata nuovamente in
Italia a giugno di quest'anno sono
tornata ufficialmente italiana e voglio
portare l'etica e la cultura della
sicurezza in Italia
continua a sentire di notizie tragiche
di incidenti sul lavoro ogni giorno
da italiana e da giovane ragazza mi
senti in dovere di cambiare questa
realtà
tutto ciò è alla portata di tutti
possiamo farlo così come è successo a
noi che abbiamo elevato in maniera
straordinaria la sicurezza in settore ad
altissimo rischio così è possibile farlo
per tutti i settori in Italia
tornata in Italia Ho iniziato a
informarmi su come viene gestito il tema
della sicurezza in Italia
ci sono sicuramente tantissime leggi
adempimenti responsabilità sia per il
datore di lavoro che per i lavoratori
nell'operatività e nella vita da
cantiere sui siti di lavoro non è poi
proprio tutto così
L'ente che si occupa di sicurezza in
Italia fa la maggior parte dei controlli
o su chiamata anonima di un dipendente o
quando la morte è già avvenuta ovvero
Controlla che le leggi gli adempimenti E
tutto quello che ci sta attorno sia o
non sia stato rispettato solo quando la
morte è già avvenuta
a voi sembra un metodo corretto o
perlomeno un metodo efficace
i dati parlano chiaro
vorrei quindi ripartire da due pilastri
di cui vi parlavo prima culture e
prevenzione
e oggi Vi presento un progetto che ho in
mente da qualche mese ormai l'ho
chiamato più sicuri è un progetto che
vuole sradicare il sistema attuale per
renderlo più efficace per migliorarlo e
per prevenire gli incidenti il progetto
più sicuri si basa sulla prevenzione e a
tre obiettivi
sensibilizzare sul tema della sicurezza
espandere la cultura della sicurezza e
prevenire gli incidenti sul lavoro
il progetto in sé è abbastanza semplice
si tratta dell'invio di un tecnico
specializzato in sicurezza all'interno
delle aziende di qualsiasi settore che
fa consulenza alle alle aziende
verificando se ci sono errori o
problematiche e dando delle soluzioni
pratiche ed immediate per migliorarsi e
per evitare possibili rischi
Questo permetterebbe alle aziende di
tutti i settori di avere una consulenza
di altissimo livello innovativa
costruttiva E assolutamente non punitiva
l'obiettivo rendere il luogo di lavoro
sicuro per tutti
gol Zero ovvero Zero incidenti e zero
morti questo deve essere l'obiettivo di
tutti questo deve essere il nostro
obiettivo perché il lavoro è vita
facciamo in modo di rimanere in vita
grazie
[Applauso]